[Music]
I've never been to the Grammys in my
life and I you presented at the Grammys
and they get every star in the world in
one row crazy
who blew you well okay so I am I know
everybody is but I'm totally obsessed
with Beyonce and I walked past Beyonce
at one point and because I'm not worthy
I did not look at her and how close were
you like backstage you did like make a
detour down the front just to walk past
Beyonce um see when your friends spot
her and thought oh yeah well just walk
past her just to get some of the aura
and and we walked past and my friend was
like dude she like she was like
motioning to you like and you just
walked past her and the panic I mean I
didn't quite know what to do but I
thought you know once in a lifetime just
do it I went back and and I just you
know I was like I'm so sorry to do this
I just wanted to meet you you're such an
inspiration and she stood up she was so
nice and she points to jay-z and was
like oh we just watched you on the
Kennedy Center Honors you were so great
you're so cute in your little red dress
and she said that I had a little red
dress which means that she actually
watched it or it means that I was having
a stroke and I imagine the entire were
you in fact wearing a little red dress
very good okay then it's probably true
so jay-z's right there that's fantastic
yeah and he's like motioning to my
friends like she's so cute she's so
excited so my friends are having like a
moment with jay-z where they're like we
are on the same level yeah
just don't say that out loud I've made
that mistake yeah we're on the same
level and then their security throws me
out she was really really nice it was a
crazy night I've never been around so
many Katy Perry finger-banged my
cleavage it was a weird night okay she
just does that she just does that I mean
if nobody does I wanted this was an
unplanned moment and I want to stay
right here
paint the scene so you're standing still
and Katy Perry walks by before and yeah
she's like that's the thing yeah you
know she's aggressive I like it okay
this is fantastic
we have you instagrammed a picture of
you went Beyonce and you did you you put
this heart around it no that was just
there so I feel like we're either gonna
be best friends or she has a restraining
order it's like but you got to go you
always have baby Perry
that relationship is solid that's
fantastic